digamos que tengo una matriz a en una
matriz y digamos que el tamaño de estas
matrices de n por acá ok y que tengo la
siguiente ecuación a por x es igual a b
muy bien entonces esto inmediatamente me
está diciendo que x como tiene cada
columnas x debe vivir en rk ok y que
además ve pues como es una
multiplicación de de una matriz de n por
k por un vector de k por uno digamos que
es una matriz de k por uno entonces ve
necesariamente tiene que vivir en rn ok
estamos buscando un vector x nrk que al
multiplicar la por esta matriz nos dé el
vector b
y ahora vamos a suponer además que esta
ecuación no tiene solución verdad
siempre buscamos la solución pero vamos
a suponer que no hay solución no hay
solución no hay solución a esta ecuación
que es x igual a b entonces vamos a
vamos a desarrollar un poquito y tengo
esta matriz vamos a desarrollarla de la
siguiente forma vamos a escribir la
matriz como casi siempre le escribimos
por sus columnas a1 a2 y así
sucesivamente hasta acá verdad son estos
as son son vectores y que multiplican a
cierto vector x cuyas coordenadas
digamos que es x 1 x 2 hasta xk ok y
esto debe ser igual a nuestro vector b
ahora bien esto por supuesto nos está
diciendo que podemos expresar el lado
izquierdo como x 1 x a 1
+ x 2 x 2 esto ya lo hemos hecho en
varios vídeos ok si si te causa
extrañeza revisa los vídeos anteriores y
finalmente xk por acá ok entonces
fíjense muy bien estamos diciendo que
esta multiplicación de una matriz por un
vector nos da una combinación lineal y
esa combinación lineal debe ser el
vector b ok es decir si no hay solución
a esta ecuación quiere decir que no
importa que pesos que pesos estamos
poniendo aquí que x1 x2 xk no importa
que pesos le estemos dando a cada uno de
estos vectores columna de la matriz eso
me está diciendo que no va a haber una
combinación lineal que nos dé
exactamente b y eso se traduce en una
sencilla en un sencillo hecho quiere
decir que ve al no poder ser combinación
lineal de las columnas de la matriz
quiere decir que el vector b no se
encuentra no se encuentra
en el espacio columna de nuestra matriz
a verdad pues sí si no puede ser una
combinación lineal de esos vectores no
puede estar en el espacio columna como
se vería esto cómo se vería esto digamos
que el espacio columna de nuestra matriz
es como una especie de plano que digamos
que es como un plano más o menos de esta
forma okay digamos que este es el
espacio columna este es el espacio
columna de nuestra matriz y que por aquí
tenemos a nuestro vector b entonces
nuestro vector b apunta más o menos
hacia acá y aquí es clarísimo que no se
encuentra en nuestro espacio columna
verdad entonces este es más o menos una
representación gráfica de lo que estamos
pintando y uno podría ponerse a decir
bueno pues no hay solución vamos a
llorar un rato pero no se trata de eso
tenemos que buscarle solución a los
problemas aunque no sean exactamente lo
que busquemos inicialmente
qué pasaría por ejemplo si yo pudiera
encontrar un vector digamos que le voy a
llamar x estrella digamos que este x
estrella es tal que
bueno x estrella donde a x estrella
aunque no sea b aunque no sea b al menos
que se parezca o que sea lo más cercano
es lo más cercano lo más cercano digamos
entre comillas en algún sentido es
cercano
es lo más cercano posible a nuestro
vector b no estamos resolviendo el
problema original de encontraron x que
me resuelve esta ecuación sin embargo lo
que estamos tratando de buscar es una
solución lo más cercano posible a ver es
decir que la distancia de x estrella al
b sea mínima y quizás ya estás viendo
hacia dónde va esta situación verdad
porque sabemos que este vector a x
estrella este que vamos a llamarle b
pues necesariamente como es una
combinación lineal de sus columnas se
encuentra en el espacio columna verdad
entonces si se encuentra en el espacio
columna lo que estamos buscando es
minimizar
la distancia debe
todos los x estrellas es decir vamos a
minimizar esta distancia verdad
vamos a minimizar esta distancia dónde
la mínima distancia es debe a la
multiplicación de a por equis estrella
verdad y si esto es nuestro vector b
quiere decir que se encuentra en el
espacio columna y ya aseguró éste le
está saliendo de qué es lo que estamos
buscando porque justamente si queremos
minimizar esta distancia
vamos a necesitar este vector b que es a
equis estrella correcto y como estamos
sobre este sub espacio vectorial que es
el espacio columna no le queda otra cosa
más que a ese a este vector a este
vector de aquí ser la proyección sobre
el espacio columna de a de nuestro
vector b eso es lo que estamos tratando
de encontrar verdad entonces vamos a
vamos a desarrollar un poquito más esto
verdad porque si queremos calcular esta
distancia digamos y este este vector de
aquí es el vector b entonces lo podemos
describir como
la norma de la diferencia la norma de la
diferencia se puede ver en un solo
vector de la siguiente forma si yo tengo
la coordenada 1 le restó la coordenada a
1 verdad la coordenada 2 le restó la
coordenada 2 y así sucesivamente
ok así sucesivamente hasta la coordenada
n le restamos la coordenada n y esto
sacamos su norma y si queremos
minimizarlo es lo mismo que minimizar al
cuadrado y ya saben que siempre sacamos
este cuadrado para hacer las operaciones
más fáciles verdad y ahora bien la norma
al cuadrado quién es pues es nuestra
nuestra primera coordenada al cuadrado
verdad es la primera coordenada al
cuadrado más la segunda coordenada b2
menos de 2 al cuadrado y así
sucesivamente sumamos estos términos
hasta obtener en menos de n
al cuadrado y queremos minimizar esto
entonces al inicio el problema digamos
que nos motivaba era en hallar una
solución mínima digamos a esta ecuación
digo no podemos encontrar la solución a
x igual a b pero podríamos ver si hay
alguna solución lo más cercana posible
verdad y ese necesariamente tiene que
estar en el espacio columna eso nos
lleva a que tenemos que minimizar esta
suma de cuadrados y de ahí que esté a
este a este señor de aquí l x estrella
tiene un nombre muy particular y que es
la solución por mínimos cuadrados este
de aquí tiene nombre y se llama la
solución por mínimos cuadrados
y ya entenderás de dónde sale sale el
nombre verdad queremos minimizar estas
diferencias que por cierto están
elevadas al cuadrado
entonces si aquí tenemos nuestro nuestro
vector b ok
ahí tenemos nuestro vector b queremos
encontrar el más cercano a este vector b
de burro correcto entonces lo que vamos
a hacer es lo siguiente no sabemos
exactamente quién sea lo único que
sabemos es que a equis estrella a equis
estrella como queremos que sea la mínima
distancia en el vídeo anterior vimos que
el vector más cercano a otro que se
encuentre sobre un sub espacio es
necesariamente la proyección entonces
queremos que esté a x estrella sea la
proyección de b sobre nuestro espacio
columna de la matriz entonces este a x
estrella para que sea mínima la
distancia debe ser la proyección sobre
el espacio columna
nuestro vector ve muy bien entonces esto
es para que realmente estemos
minimizando está esta distancia y que
por lo tanto estamos encontrando el
vector más cercano posible a ver
entonces si tenemos esto vamos a notar
lo siguiente qué pasaría si vamos a
restar de ambos lados el vector de este
vector este vector b devour muy bien
entonces si por ejemplo del lado del
lado izquierdo que tenemos
a equis estrella a equis estrella le
restamos le restamos el vector b vamos a
restarle el vector b eso debe ser igual
del otro lado tenemos la proyección la
proyección sobre el espacio columna de
la matriz de nuestro vector b y le
estamos restando ve muy bien le estamos
restando ve ahora cómo se ve eso si yo
tengo fíjense muy bien en el lado
derecho entonces tengo la proyección de
b sobre el espacio columna y le voy a
restar b eso es la diferencia de dos
vectores es el vector que apunta de uno
al otro
verdad entonces esta diferencia es el
que apunta hacia aquí y podemos ver que
va de aquí a acá porque ve más este
vector que es esta diferencia si yo
tengo ve más esto las veces cancelan y
me queda la proyección de b que es
justamente este vector entonces este
vector de aquí
este naranja que es este este de aquí lo
que un me está diciendo es que es
ortogonal es ortogonal a todo el espacio
columna verdad y eso lo sabíamos ya por
construcción por como hemos definido las
proyecciones eso quiere decir
inmediatamente como este vector es este
otro quiere decir que a equis estrella
menos b se encuentra en el espacio
columna perdón en el complemento
ortogonal al espacio columna verdad
porque éste forma un ángulo de 90 grados
con todo el espacio muy bien pero
sabemos además que también ya hemos
visto en otros vídeos que el complemento
ortogonal del espacio columna de una
matriz no es otra cosa más que el
espacio nulo izquierdo
es decir el espacio nulo de nuestra
matriz transpuesta o bien esto también
me está diciendo como este vector a x
estrella menos b se encuentra en el
complemento ortogonal del espacio
columna y ese es el espacio nulo
izquierdo entonces este vector quiere
decir que a x estrella menos b se
encuentra en el espacio nulo de la
matriz a transpuesta muy bien y eso
algebraica mente se ve de esta forma
quiere decir que si yo multiplico a
transpuesta por a x estrella menos b
donde recordemos que x estrella es
nuestra solución o también le llaman la
aproximación por mínimos cuadrados esto
por estar en el espacio nulo de esta
matriz nos tiene que dar el vector
ok entonces si nos da el vector 0 eso al
ir lo desarrollando podemos escribirlo
de la siguiente forma porque esto lo
podemos distribuir correcto nada más
vamos antes de distribuir a repasar un
poquito qué es lo que estábamos haciendo
recordemos que tenemos a equis estrella
me igual a b que perdón tenemos a x
igual a b queremos resolver esto pero
resulta que no hay solución no tenemos
solución bueno en vez de ponernos a
llorar porque no hay una solución
podríamos pensar si encontrar algún
vector x estrella tal que la distancia
ave sea lo más cercano posible entonces
eso nos decía que necesariamente tiene
que ser la proyección sobre el espacio
columna y de ser esto cierto quiere
decir que se cumplen estas propiedades y
llegamos a esto entonces si continuamos
distribuyendo esta multiplicación vamos
a tener que
a transpuesta por equis estrella por a x
estrella y luego menos a transpuesta por
b es igual al vector cero y si sumamos
este de ambos lados tenemos que ha
transpuesto por a x estrella es igual a
a transpuesta por el vector b y esto es
lo que nos va a dar una nueva ecuación
para resolver el problema de mínimos
cuadrados para minimizar este problema
entonces recordemos que teníamos a x a x
igual a b tal que no tiene solución esto
va sin solución
sin solución muy bien entonces estábamos
buscando nuestro x estrella tal que
minimizará que minimiza minimiza esta
distancia
la distancia bebé a por equis estrella
ok de todos los posibles x x estrella es
el que hace que esta distancia sea
mínima y eso nos lleva como dijimos a
que éste tiene que ser la proyección
sobre el espacio columna de la matriz
del vector b ok entonces tenemos
justamente que a x estrella a x estrella
es igual a la proyección a la proyección
sobre el espacio columna de la matriz
debe ok y como tenemos esta relación si
nos damos cuenta si la comparamos con
esta esta roja que tenemos aquí al lado
por ejemplo tenemos a x
y si multiplicamos del lado izquierdo
por a transpuesta esto me va a dar igual
a transpuesta verdad por b
por el vector b que es justamente esta
relación entonces esta ecuación esta
ecuación al resolverla es la que me va a
dar el vector que va a ser el la
solución por mínimos cuadrados mínimos
cuadrados esta esta ecuación al
resolverla entonces no tenemos que hay
una matriz aquí la transpuesta a y hay
un vector de este lado siempre que se
pueda hallar una solución en esta
ecuación ese vector x estrella va a ser
nuestro mejor intento para hallar una
solución de x igual a b que no la hay
pero es nuestra solución más cercana que
podemos dar entonces de esta forma hemos
minimizado el error estamos minimizando
la distancia de ax a b y eso será
nuestra solución de mínimos cuadrados
todo esto yo sé que está muy abstracto
en este vídeo pero con suerte en el
próximo nos daremos cuenta de que es un
concepto muy pero muy útil